-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back to the
captain's quarters.
As we mentioned, my parents
visited this past week,
and on Tuesday,
we showed you my father
giving his tough-love feedback
to the sea captain,
but my mom also chimed in.
So we're gonna show you
her far gentler response
at the end of tonight's show.
I should also note that
next week will be
our final shows in this
location, which is sad.
It's really sad, because
that barely gives us time
to introduce popular
new characters
like the fish
who probably has a drug problem.
-Hi, guys.
Can I borrow 50 bucks?
-What's it for, Steve?
-What do you need it for, Steve?
-I need it for bus fare,
my mom hurt her knee,
and investment opportunities.
-Oh, Steve.
-You need help, Steve.
-Isn't it a shame
we don't have time for that?
Anyway, Senator Kamala Harris
made her first public appearance
as Joe Biden's
running mate yesterday
while President Trump
and his allies
strained to come up
with increasingly
ridiculous ways to attack her.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Yesterday, Biden and Harris
made their first
campaign appearance together,
and it was a historic moment,
with Harris becoming
the first black woman
and the first Asian-American to
appear on a major party ticket,
which sets up quite a contrast
with the
Republican Vice President,
whose 23andMe DNA profile
came back 92% Irish ghost.
The other 8% was English ghost.
Harris had her first chance
to go after Trump
as the Democratic candidate
for Vice President,
and she took aim squarely
at his response
to the coronavirus pandemic.
-When other countries
are following the science,
Trump pushed miracle cures
he saw on Fox News.
-"It's not a miracle.
It works.
If you chug a full bottle
of Pepto Bismol,
stick a hairdryer up your butt,
and flush a double-A battery
down the toilet,
you can cure coronavirus.
If you don't believe me,
just ask this Fauci puppet
my staff made me
because the real Fauci
puts me in a bad mood."
-Side note here --
in case there are any
conservatives who hate-watch
"A Closer Look,"
I should say, for safety's sake,
that double-A battery cure
doesn't really work.
You have to use a 9-volt.
Biden announced his pick
of Harris via text on Tuesday,
and when he heard the news,
Mike Pence immediately
tried to hide
by blending into the background.
"She can't debate me
if she can't see me."
At the V.P. debate in October,
Pence is gonna send a mannequin
and a recorder in his place,
Ferris Bueller-style,
and hope no one notices.
"Thank you, Senator Harris.
Mr. Vice President,
your rebuttal."
[ Cassette tape button
clicking, snoring ]
"Okay. Well, it sounds like
he's asleep.
Senator Harris, back to you."
When the news was announced
on Tuesday,
Pence tried
to put on a brave face
as opposed to his usual...
no face?
Although I'm not sure bravado
is really a posture
that works well for Mike Pence.
-On the way here, I just heard
that Joe Biden
named his running mate.
[ Laughter ]
California Senator Kamala Harris
will be the Democratic candidate
for Vice President.
-Four more years!
-You all might like to know that
the vice-presidential debate
is gonna be held on October 7th
in Utah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So my message to the Democratic
candidate for Vice President,
congratulations.
I'll see you in Salt Lake City.
-Is there anyone in the world
with less swagger
than Mike Pence?
Watching him try to act cocky
is like watching an Amish
grandpa dance at a wedding.
"Hey, macarena."
And, look, I know Pence
didn't pick the debate location,
but is there a whiter throwdown
in history
than "See you
in Salt Lake City"?
That's like hearing someone say,
"Why don't we settle
our differences at
the Williams-Sonoma
Instant Pot aisle,
8:00 a.m. sharp,
'cause I got pilates at 9:00."
They really have no idea
how to attack Harris.
They're flailing.
First, they criticized the way
Biden made the announcement.
White House press secretary
Kayleigh McEnany tweeted...
Good point, Kayleigh.
The Internet
is just a passing fad.
The future is all about
network television.
Also, did you forget
that the guy you work for
uses Twitter so much
he had his phone
surgically attached to his face?
Not only did Trump announce his
V.P. pick on Twitter in 2016,
the dude even fires people on
Twitter because he's too scared
to talk to them face to face.
If Trump ever dumps Pence
from the ticket,
we're gonna find out
from a tweet that says,
"Can someone ask Mike
to bring me a Diet Coke
before security escorts him
from the building?"
Also, this basement
talking point is so dumb.
Say what you want about the guy,
but he's out in public
all the time making speeches,
riding bikes,
driving a Stingray
in his Aviators
like a grandpa
who's on the prowl.
"Grandpa, where are you going?"
"I'm going down to bingo night
to meet some ladies.
Don't wait up."
"Grandpa, it's 3:00
in the afternoon."
Trump is the one who spends
all his time
haunting his own golf course
like the legend
of Haggard Vance.
-Eh. It's a slant rhyme,
but I'll allow it.
-Also, we're all
in our basements.
It's a pandemic.
I spent the first half
of the summer talking to
the wasps in my attic
and the second half
befriending a sea captain
painting, a wooden duck,
and a fish who keeps
asking me for Sudafed.
-Well, I have a cold!
-You don't have a cold, Steve!
-You need help, Steve.
-And, again, everybody,
after tonight,
only four more shows
with all these guys.
But just because
we love your feedback,
we're posting a new poll
on twitter @SeaCaptainPolls,
where your options will be,
"I think the sea captain
was a nice addition during
a difficult time,"
or "I hate fun."
But Trump and his allies on Fox
really think
this dumb basement talking point
is a political winner.
Here's Sean Hannity
straining to find something
he can criticize about the way
Biden announced Harris' pick.
-And just today the Biden
campaign photographer --
look at this --
they released a picture
showing Joe
talking to Kamala Harris.
Look at what you see there.
There appears to be a script
in the picture,
and Joe actually
has his phone backwards.
-Oh, my goodness.
A script for a politician?
What's next, a podium?
"Look at what you see.
Joe Biden appears to be
standing behind
some sort of tiny wooden house.
And why does he have
his name on the sign?
So he can remember it?"
At least when Biden uses a
script, he can actually read it,
unlike a good friend of yours.
-When they gaze upon
yo-semites -- yo-seminite's
towering sequoias...
I want to also thank the
Mindianapolis police department.
They have been so incredible.
Mindianapolis.
They sacrifice every day
for the furniture --
future of their children.
Prevent Iran
from developing an Internet --
This is so totally important --
an intercontinental
ballistic missile.
-I know Trump's a teetotaler,
but whenever he's
reading off a script,
he has the exact mannerisms
of a guy who's desperately
trying to hide
that he's drunk at work.
That's why he's always
swaying back and forth
even when
he's trying to stand still.
[ Slurring ] "As you can see
from this slide,
quarterly prostitutes -- and
this is so totally important.
But quarterly profits are...
at an all-time high.
And on this next slide,
you can see that --
I totally love you guys."
And then there's Trump,
who tried maybe
the dumbest attack of all.
The only thing he could come up
with was complaining
that she was too mean
to Brett Kavanaugh.
-And now you have
sort of a madwoman, I call her,
because she was so angry
and such hatred
with Justice Kavanaugh.
I mean, I've never
seen anything like it.
She was the angriest of the
group, and they were all angry.
-She was extraordinarily nasty
to Kavanaugh,
Judge Kavanaugh then,
now Justice Kavanaugh.
She was nasty to a level
that was just a horrible thing.
I thought she was the meanest,
the most horrible,
most disrespectful
of anybody in the U.S. Senate.
-These guys love
to joke about liberal tears,
but they are the whiniest
little babies in the world.
Trump sounds like he's sniffling
to his mom
after getting home
from the playground.
"She was the meanest,
most horrible,
most disrespectful bully.
She gave me a wedgie."
Also, you really think
that's a winner?
She was mean to John Hughes
villain Brett Kavanaugh,
the guy who looks like
he's in a "Where are they now?"
about the preppy bad kid
from "Goonies"?
"My father will turn
this entire neighborhood
into a country club."
Hey, Speaking of villains
from John Hughes movies,
I now have only one week left
to achieve my summer goal
of Steph
from "Pretty in Pink" hair.
It's gonna be close,
but I really hope I can do it.
-I believe in you.
-You can do it.
-I'm high all the time.
-Trump and his allies
are flailing as they come up
with increasingly absurd attacks
on Harris.
All they have so far are their
usual dumb insults.
You know,
attacks that are just...
-Meanest, the most horrible,
most disrespectful.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
-I like you, Sea Captain.
-More than you like the duck?
-Yeah, that means no.
-Sorry, Sea Captain.
-Hillary!
♪♪
-Now more than ever,
City Harvest needs your help
feeding New York families
hit by the COVID crisis.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask, we love you.